توترات شبت في منطقه مروي في الولايه
الشماليه في السودان قد تنسف معها امال
توقيع اتفاق لنقل السلطه شراره اشتعلت بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع توشي
بان خلافات خطيره بين الطرفين تطفو بينهما
قربى مروى حيث قرر الجيش نشر قوات في
المدينه تحسبا لاي انفلات امني قد يدخل
البلاد في منعطف خطير خاصه وان ذروه هذا
التوتر تفاقمت خلال الساعات الماضيه مع
وصول اكثر من 100 سياره من الدعم السريع
الى السور الذي انشاته قرب مطار مروي لكن
قوات الدعم السريع اكدت ان وجودها ياتي في
اطار تاديه المهام المناطه بهم نافيه انها
لم تنسق مع قياده القوات المسلحه وبقيه
القوات النظاميه الاخرى
ثلاثه
هو متحرك
وعلى وقع هذه التوترات في منطقه مروي في
الولايه الشماليه بالسودان حذر الجيش من
ان السودان يمر في منعطف خطير بعد حجز
الدعم السريع قوته داخل العاصمه وبعض
المدن مؤكدا ان تحركات قوات الدعم السريع
تمت من دون موافقه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومن دون تنسيق معها
وجب علينا ان ندق ناقوس الخطر
بان بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
وتزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن هذه التحركات
والانفتاحات تمت دون موافقه قياده القوات
المسلحه او مجرد التنسيق معها
مما اثار الهلع والخوف في اوساط مواطنين
وفاقم من المخاطر الامنيه وزاد من التوتر
بين القوات النظاميه
بيان القوات المسلحه السودانيه ابدى عدم
الرغبه في نشوب الصراع المسلح واوضح ان
اعاده تمركز قوات الدعم السريع يخالف مهام
ونظام عملها وهو في تجاوز واضح للقانون
لم تنقطع محاولات القوات المسلحه في ايجاد
الحلول السلميه لهذه التجاوزات وذلك حفاظا
على الطمانينه العامه وعدم الرغبه في نشوب
صراع مسلح يقضي على الاخضر واليابس لان
هذه الانفتاحات واعاده تمركز القوات
يخالف مهام ونظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات لجان الامنيه
واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما الى المزيد من
الانقسامات والتوترات التي ربما تقود الى
انفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد
وفي مطلع الشهر الجاري كان الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني نبيل عبد الله قد اكد ان
التوقع او التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي
للعمليه السياسيه مرهون بوضع جداول زمنيه
لدمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش ويعد
تعثر الاتفاق على دمج قوات الدعم السريع
والمدن والمدى الزمني ابرز نقاط الخلاف
بينهما لا سيما وانا قوات الدعم السريع
تطالب بفتره الزمنيه للانتقال تصل الى عشر
سنوات وذكر الجيش السوداني ان تكون هذه
الفتره الانتقاليه لعامين قائلا انه لا
يمكن الدخول في انتخابات بوجود اكثر من
جيش واحد في البلاد
[موسيقى]
واحد
شعب واحد شعب واحد
شعب واحد
[موسيقى]
شع
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نزار
البقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار اذا يعني في
ظل هذه التوترات وفي ظل تحركات للدعم او
قوى الدعم السريع في الولايه الشماليه
وخصوصا في مدينه او منطقه ميراوي ما
التحركات المتوقعه والمرتقبه لقياده الجيش
وقياده قوات الدعم السريع
نعم يعني ساعات المقبله هي ساعات حاسمه في
عمر المشهد السياسي والمشهد الامني
والمشهد اجتماعي هنا في السودان ذلك
لاهميه ولحساسيه هذه التحركات لقوات الدعم
السريع وتمركز الجيش وانفتاح الجيش في
منطقه مروي العسكريه بالولايه الشماليه
هذه التطورات واجزاء ما قال به الجيش
السوداني صباح هذا اليوم من ان البلاد تمر
بمنعطف خطير بعد هذه التحركات لقوات الدعم
السريع نترقب نحن هنا في الخرطوم تحركات
مكوكيه سواء كانت داخل القياده العامه
للجيش او داخل قياده الدعم السريع هذا من
جانب هنالك بعض التحركات لبعض الفاعلين
الدوليين وذلك لخلق اجواء من التهدئه بعد
حاله الاعتقان التي استهدت الاجواء
الامنيه والعسكريه خلال الساعات الماضيه
ربما يكون هنالك تحرك للفاعلين الدوليين
لمنظومه الترويكا لبعض السفارات هنا في
الخرطوم لبعض القوى السياسيه المكونه
المدني القوى الحريه والتغيير حزب الامه
القومي كل هذه القوى السياسيه الان تنظر
بعين الترقب وتتخوف من ان تنهار العمليه
السياسيه التي بدات منذ الخامس من ديسمبر
الماضي بالتالي الان الكل يترقب ما هي
الحلول ما هي مسارات الحل انفراج هذه
الازمه التي وصلت الى مستوى عالي من
الحساسيه بين قياده الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه
ان هناك اجتماع مرتقب بين الجانبين هل بدا
هذا الاجتماع هل هناك بوادر لاي حل حلالي
الازمه الحاصله
يعني حتى اللحظه لم يكون هنالك اي معلومات
حول التوقيت الزماني لانعقاد هذا الاجتماع
اجتماع مجلس الامن والدفاع وهو يدوم يضم
القياده العليا في الجيش والمؤسسه الامنيه
والعسكريه والشرطيه وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا الاجتماع من المفترض ان يناقش
الحيثيات والتداعيات والقرارات التي يجب
ان تتخذ لوضع جديد يتعلق بمهام قوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان هنالك اتفاق سياسي وهنالك
عمليه سياسيه ارتات ان يتم دمج قوات الدعم
السريع عليه فان هذا الاجتماع له اهميه له
حساسيه له درجه من الاهميه لانه سيضع
الامور في نصابها وسيحدد كيف ستمضي الامور
خلال الساعات المقبله خاصه اذا اشرنا الى
ان قوات الدعم السريع كانت قد تلقت
معلومات من قبل الجيش السوداني بضروره ان
يتم الانسحاب من قاعده مروي العسكريه وهو
ما لم يتم حتى اللحظه التي تتحدث فيها طيب
نزار الانباء تتحدث عن مبادرات امميه
واقليميه وجهود تحدث خلف الكواليس هل من
انباء حول ذلك
نعم يعني على الصعيد المحلي والصعيد
السياسي الان حزب الامه القومي ينشد عبر
رئيسه الجنرال فضلا لبرمه ناصر الرجل الان
قال قبل قليل بانه سيجد وسيبحث اي مسار
يفضي الى حلحله الازمه السياسيه والازمه
السودانيه والازمه الراهنه بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني مساء هذا
اليوم ايضا هنالك منتدا اعلامي لمجموعه
المجلس المركزي بقوه الحريه والتغيير مؤكد
بان الظلال ما حدث يوم امس واليوم بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع سيكون
حاضرا بحسبان ان العمليه السياسيه مرتبطه
ارتباطا وثيقا وجديا بمستوى التفاهمات بين
الجيش وبين قوات الدعم السريع ايضا من
الانباء التي لم تصدر حتى الان بان هنالك
تحركات ربما تكون الاليه الثلاثيه باعتبار
انها ايضا ميسره لعمليه سياسيه ومن
مصلحتها ان تكون الاجواء مهيئه لعقد اتفاق
سياسي بين الفرقه السودانيين شكرا لك من
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه نزار البداوي
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات